what the [__] you think you're dealing
with math flavor here making your Monday
a little bit better uncle Joey not a
[__] had a sunshine in the sky it's
the sunshine in your heart and your
nutsack that makes a lot better
[__] uncle Joey here with the
morning joint I know it's a little late
I had to run some errands this morning
you know how the [__] it is you gotta go
do this do that this guy wants a talkin
it's all [__] nonsense but it doesn't
matter cuz I'm here with you right now
Joey bull what's with the chitter
chatter break up a [__] reefer that
make the guy from Def Leppard cut off
his [__] arm forget about it when I
got for you today is something out of
[__] Hills these guys are some friends
of mine and they grow some [__]
reason it's like 30% I got the paperwork
or beat 26 [__] comes in a [__]
stink sack you know saying I stink sack
is how we do it [__] oh [__]
just what the doctor ordered [__] Dr
Pepper Dr Pepper can't do dick with this
we don't do da young Sam will beat this
morning into the murky waters of the
underworld I know it's Monday
you're waking up [__] all that [__] it's
any other day so bring on the [__]
day you people yeah go [__] yourself you
gotta be prepared ready for [__] war
Mike make beer shows I am ready for war
he [__] don't know what you're
missing
I'm still here stone color [__]
deville devotion listening to Tony
Bennett my wife is in there [__] back
even like a savage and that's it who's
better than me we better the [__] New
York [__] I'm looking to hang
out with not me nobody's looking hang
out with me I'm not gonna how were you
it's Monday you got home [__] wait
you're gonna sit that over jello gives a
[__]
go get one go cut a [__] sweet I
don't give a [__] what you need to do
it's action remember you gotta keep
moving to create a [__] wind
[__] paint and that might not
happen you just stand-in there and then
what my buddy said he's gonna get me a
job in a plant in March who gives a [__]
it's March [__] to March 2016
grab that [__] sharpen that [__]
go out there and get what belongs to you
just weirdest [__] good day [__]
around these [__] are b-26 up
there
Oh oh [__] I'm have to go inside listen
to [__] meet the Beatles my main man
Sergio Ortega I got some albums this
week's lump in my little polar region
buddy gift left us some Reese's Pieces
there's a farm we're gonna see the
[__] Devil Wears water box of
Cleo's out there my man [__] Larry
over there in Vegas running [__] running
[__] Vegas oh yeah I'm here smoking dope
with you [__] but guess what I'm
up [__] were all my heart
that's why I do this [__] if I wouldn't
love you mother funny thing I'd be out
here [__] no I'd be somewhere trying to
write a [__] joke exactly
Oh
oh yeah well it tastes smoother than
[__] yeah miss Pam penises this is a
master plan these guys more advice
please guys don't [__] around look it's
still cloudy there's smoke it's a
beautiful light fluffy
I don't know [__] it's 4/20 some way and
I'm saying I've never even known what
the [__] what when he was nipple Scott
the squirrel Hawaii mr. squirrel
oh yeah oh yeah I don't know what to
tell you mother flies you gotta do what
you gotta do I don't give a [__] about
st. Patty's Day no Monday is st. big day
that's what it is to me you got like
what think that what belongs to you I
get your [__] lunch box you gotta get
your life you gotta fill it all these
[__] know what the terms are
for the [__] new week can you
understand because every week we have
new [__] terms we get stronger and
stronger so the terms [__] change I'm
saying get your act together get out
this stabbed my mother [__] I don't give
a [__] what you got to do to prove your
point that it's [__] Monday [__]
hey the clock the church tonight nice
guest smoke some hash out of a [__]
glass make me sweat like a [__] yeah
that tell you guys I love smoking reefer
with you [__] this is the best
part of my Vegas hanging out with you
guys chitchat it's Monday
wonderful to jump up and down y'all have
pictures at a bar with people and she is
get off our girly
like smoking reefer outside a little
reef a little vitamin B when there's no
sunshine just a fresh [__] in I'm
gonna be in a bar talking a bunch of
[__] jerk-offs about the presidential
campaign who gives a [__]
man who's present you still gotta get up
and do your [__] thing right
wake me up when the president shows up
just give me [__] 40 a day to smoke
reefer I'll have to pay right that's a
[__] president everybody else could
suck my dick and call me shorty I was
born in 1940 what do you think so we
smoked one more bowl and take it to the
murky waters beep I'm already hitting
people yelling and kids screaming what
do you think darling I'm only we're both
tired I see a new nickel buddy oh yeah
and to it there's an egg but on the bus
when I land on their walk they think I
put on bossy for look Pete - Luda oh
[__] look at my girl coming up tears
until [__] Becky MacDougall's here
what's happening we're here blowing a
[__] number Oh
I thought it was the cops would you
bring its [__] Monday morning I'll
take a hit
how the [__] you gotta come out of his
church [__] little it's a little hit
some nice weave before you podcast at
11:00 we go to Jitsu at 12:00 Becky just
showed up and [__] she's gonna go meet
Lee I was thinking about you last night
I was too late to call you though I saw
you put pictures up with barn flyers and
[__] like that see what happens you
don't know who's only pop-up always
affirmed it's always a surprise here on
the balcony of life while Mike is making
love you guys want to see how we do it
odd cast and made [__] easy
[__]
I'll see you guys later have a great day
stay black you uncle Joey loves you